the Commission have been able to act
very quickly if you can't find common
solutions to common problems what's the
point of the EU member said you realize
that they really need each other we will
come out of this with a stronger
corporation it's not as if scientists
hadn't been warning for a long time
about a pandemic they had but the
politicians in many European countries
didn't seem to take much notice the
scale of their lack of preparation is
only now becoming clear my guest this
week from Brussels is the European
Commissioner for Home Affairs bhuva
Johansson a former minister in her
native Sweden just why do europe and the
EU get it so wrong
[Music]
une vie your Hansen welcome to conflict
zone thank you we've seen high levels of
disunity on show across the EU during
this pandemic you would agree that it's
been a major blow to the EU s
credibility hasn't it this disunity no I
don't agree with that at all actually we
have seen our desperate actions from
member states and that's quite
understandable because we are in a
situation where never been before and
the crisis is really really a big one
but we are also seeing our member states
asking for the EU Commission to take a
stronger role to do more to coordinate
more also in areas where we do not
really have the mandate as a commission
so I don't really agree with you on that
well last months the French finance
minister Bruno lemare said to his
squabbling colleagues after an all-night
meeting to try and agree a rescue
package shame on you shame on Europe
stop this clown show do you like the
epithet clown show no but of course this
is very difficult and you must
understand that also that all
governments are under very strong
pressure in a way that they haven't been
any anyway before and that this is a
difficult situation for member states of
course to agree on things and we have
seen a border being closed in a not so
coordinated manners we have seen and
restrictions export restrictions and
things like that and it is difficult to
come along with an you are economical
proposals but at the same time we have
also seen when we see how things develop
member states are coming closer to each
other and they are asking for the
Commission to play a more or stronger
role and we and we do that and I think
that the Commission has been able to act
very quickly and sometimes when I see
how member states act I make them
I do their comparison with but
individuals you know when this first
attacked us and in March you can see
individuals rushing to their grocery
store shopping and shops a lot of toilet
paper and plastic I understand that
Commissioner but when they were needed
initially when the pandemic struck they
weren't there were they commissioner
President as you love and alliance said
when Europe really needed to be there
for each other
too many initially looked out for
themselves when Europe really needed an
all for one spirit too many initially
gave an only for me response you say
it's difficult to agree this is this is
the whole point of the EU that you come
you are able to agree if you can't find
common solutions to common problems
what's the point of the EU but you have
to see how things are moving the initial
the initial reaction was from
individuals to look at themselves for
Member States to look at themselves from
companies to look at themselves but
quite soon their movement went in
another direction
asking for more coordination more
cooperation and asking for the
Commission to play a stronger role and I
think that we as a commission has also
been able to play that stronger role and
we still have to do it because it's a
long way to go before we have before
we're through this and also I think that
but if you ask me I will rather guests
that we will come out of this with a
stronger corporation in the European
Union than before but of course has been
initially a lot of disruptions and and
problems but it wasn't just initially
was these problems commissioner it
wasn't just initially was it I mean
we've had four failed summits by video
EU leaders have gone on rowing and
disagreeing meeting after meeting
week after week the last failed summit
was on April of 24th in which they were
unable to resolve deep divisions over
the proposed recovery fund and the
amount of cash it it should distribute
my question to you is don't millions
Europeans who were locked up in their
homes losing their jobs finding it
either tough or impossible to pay their
bills many suffering food poverty for
the first time in their life shouldn't
they expect something better from these
leaders from these member countries it's
okay for you agree that well may I say
that of course individuals should have
high expectations on the cooperation
between member states in the European
Union but that we have summits that fail
to come to conclusion is not a new
phenomena that's how it's been all the
time in the European Union and prava was
difficult all right already from the
beginning to find a compromise and of
course now when the needs are much much
bigger there's a need of much more money
into this of course it's not easier to
come to conclusions especially not when
you're not meeting face to face so I
don't think that we should use this this
is not in my view this is not what we
are seeing is not a failure of European
Union we have a lot of difficulties of
course but they say these are not new
difficulties and we can manage them not
another failure brunella miracles in a
clown show and and French president
Emmanuel macron says if the EU is going
to die it will die from inaction you say
that you get disagreements all the time
in the EU but this is a critical
situation this this is a life and death
crisis you would expect better under
these circumstances wouldn't you you
seem very tolerant of all this
incompetence and squabbling well I think
of course it is a very critical
situation and a very dangerous situation
because the needs are very big for a lot
of actions and I'd also think that this
will lead us to that we will are that
the Member States will be able to come
to compromise that will be acceptable
and that will help us out of this so I
don't think that what we have seen the
problems we are seeing are not really
new ones well you say this but
none of this infighting of course is
apparent from the glowing picture which
emerges from the --use PR machine which
of course presented the response in such
glowing terms I have to say it reminded
me slightly of the old Soviet newspaper
Pravda when it talked about countries
regions cities across the EU were
extending a helping hand to neighbors
and those most in need with donations of
protective equipment nothing about the
fact that a lot of them were put under
temporary export bans because they
weren't going to give Italy what they
wanted this is particularly France and
Germany and then the the PR machine says
this is European solidarity at its best
it isn't is it I mean for you to put out
a slanted view like this but at the time
when you're telling the world you're
fighting disinformation is pretty
hypocritical isn't it there's a very
important difference between this
comparison with Pravda
we are a union of M democracies and this
is the most important thing that we
stick to our values and what can
actually be very was sometimes worries
me as if there are member states that
will take this opportunity of the crisis
to take step away from democracy and
away from the rule of law this is this
is what worries me the most then we have
member states of course with governments
that are under pressures under under
pressure and there is a difficult
situation and when the democracies and
democratic states are coming together of
course there's a lot of discussions and
sometimes there are very hot feelings
but I'm sure that we gonna be able to
manage this together and I think that
it's very important to make a
distinction we are not having any
problem we are having a union of
democracies well Donald Tusk and now
President of the European People's Party
said I hope everything can be fixed but
the loss of reputation is huge he's
talking about damage that the initial
responses and the constant Rao
has already done and if you look at
Italy you've seen Carlo calendar ahead
of the pro-european liberal Action Party
declaring this is an existential threat
I'm not sure if we're going to make it
you have to consider my party is one of
the most Pro European parties in Italy
and I now have members writing to me
saying why do we want to stay in the EU
it's useless
so there has been damage done despite
the comforting words that you're using
today yeah but it's also the opposite
it's also the way that people are I
really have a high expectation of the
European Union and we can also see
member states are cooperating and asking
for a stronger Commission and a stronger
coordination and cooperation within the
European Union and what I also see is
that members that realize that they
really need each other and you can make
their comparison if they if we had this
crisis and we didn't have the European
Union the crisis would have been huge
much much worse than today so we have
the opportunity to work together we are
working together and of course in a
crisis you can see tendencies of
different er and directions but there is
also a lot of strong tendencies towards
closer cooperation and helping each
other well let's look if we may at how
the Commission has handled this crisis
because on February the fifth one of
your officials at a closed-door meeting
with diplomats said things are under
control there is a strong level of
preparedness in Member States this was
February the fifth a strong level of
preparedness in Member States most have
measures to detect and treat kovat 19 at
the time 60 million people were under
lockdown in China and everything was big
about to become very much out of control
wasn't it why didn't you check with the
member states who were giving you such
reassurance about their state of
preparedness pretty sloppy wasn't it
from the Commission we had the whole the
whole area of a health care and
protection of our pandemic
the national competence so member states
have this competence and they have been
dealing with it but we saw when this
crisis and epidemic was here was that
Member State asked the Commission to
take a stronger role even if we do not
have that formal mandate to act in the
area of health care and I think this is
a sign that member states would like to
cooperate closer and would like to see a
stronger role from the Commission but
you care about the wrong message has may
I just finish my sentence in my view the
Commission acted stronger and quicker
than I think that most of the member
states and others could have expected
you gave out the wrong message though
things were not under control were they
it's a dangerous message to put back
well I verify your your quotas there so
I don't know but if member states are in
the if members they thought they were
under control of course this is the
competence of the member states but now
they see that they do not deal with this
a good-enough alone that's why they are
asking for the Commission to play to
take a stronger role and and to
coordinate more and we are doing that
one of the things that has happened
because of the lack of preparedness and
the lack of coordination is that the EU
has open the door to a whole bunch of
fraudulent and corrupt procurement deals
hasn't it this could take years to sort
out in Reverse
none of that gets printed in your fact
sheets does it why not well I think you
are not really right there of course
it's the free to deal and to have
commerce and trade with with other
companies from other part of the world
but what I see from the angle of
security is that organised criminals has
been very quick to adapt to the new
situation and a lot of new opportunities
for organized crimes have been
we saw that coming already a long time
before but now it has boomed so this is
the reason why we really need to step up
the law enforcement are to be able to
deal better in this digital world that
we are dealing with so this is a also an
area where we don't see the need for
more cooperation between member states
more cooperation but at a time of crisis
it has opened the door to to organized
crime in a big way in Italy the European
country perhaps hardest hit by this
pandemic the organized crime and
corruption reporting project found that
state contracts were awarded to
companies whose heads had been accused
of fraud and misappropriation of public
funds in Slovenia the government's
largest of its 19 contract worth more
than 25 million euros went to a gambling
mogul with no known experience in
medical procurement and so then this
goes on this is hardly satisfactory is
it well we have a lot of criminal actors
of course and how we should deal with
this is of course we will not be easier
to deal with for Member States alone we
really need the cooperation and we need
a strong Europe all to be able to deal
with this and we have also been able to
get some of these criminals also into
court to court because of the
cooperation between the European Union
so I do not agree with you that the
solutions would be easier to deal with
this for Member States alone but for
some for the criminals now it's a field
day isn't it well some of them have been
very quick to adapt to the new situation
and that's why it's so important that we
could have the law enforcement fit for
the digital age and in my view there is
need to do even more in this area and
that's what we are proposing preparing
for proposals for a new strategy let's
look at the proposals for the recovery
package it's said to be worth anything
up to several trillion euros and is
going to be linked apparently to the
European Union budget being drafted by
your Commission and will be submitted to
EU leaders later this month and then the
squabbling begins again doesn't it we
squabbling because the problem is that
in this package which is going to be a
mixture of loans and grants there's
still no agreement among states about
the proportions is there well now and no
it's no agreement yet and there's no
proposal yet so but of course it's gonna
be difficult it's always difficult to
find these kind of agreements but I'm
quite convinced that we will reach it
always difficult to say it's always
difficult we doesn't cut it when you
have a crisis of these proportions and
one of the biggest economic setbacks
since the Great Depression in the 1930s
it's the same that is always difficult
but doesn't doesn't live up to people's
grand expectations of the European Union
do they expect more well I do not really
agree with you on that because people
have expectations from their governments
to act on national level and they have
expectations on how European Union
should act together and member states
have different views on what is the most
appropriate way to act them they have
also different needs and different
abilities so this is our democracies
Democratic leaders come together this is
the most important thing also to discuss
this to find an agreement and of course
when we are talking about so much money
and such a big crisis nobody could say
it easy to find an agreement but I'm
quite convinced we will reach it but
it's gonna be a bumpy way I guess so you
may be convinced that you're gonna reach
it but the signs aren't good are they
the northern EU states want to see
mostly loans the southern states are
insisting on grants because they don't
want their already massive debts piling
up for leaders to come so the sage is
set for another enormous rather disunity
just goes on and on and the crisis will
get deeper the economic crisis will get
deeper want it I think well I don't I'm
not that negative as you are I know when
we have these difficult terms and
different views from members
on how to act on on bonds or grants or
loans this is of course nothing new and
it's also been a difficult already
before the pandemic to find agreement on
the new mff so of course it's difficult
but of course we're gonna make it yeah
but you you have a record of failure in
past crises don't you the u.s. built on
this terrible record I'm thinking about
the the migrant issue for instance
something of direct interest to you with
your portfolio in the EU here's a
current snapshot of how migrants are
dealt with in the EU motor keeping 60 of
them on a ship anchored at sea until the
EU can rehouse them is that a humane
response in line with EU values well I
do not agree that the European Union is
built on failures I think that we are
being built actually of a lot of a
difficult but actually quite successful
cooperation of course they are
difficulties and in my view it was a it
is a failure that Member States and
Parliament have not been able to reach
an agreement on the proposals on a
common European migration and asylum
proposal that was presented by the
previous Commission so this is my task
now to present a new proposal that
hopefully can get everybody on board and
find it acceptable for everybody we have
60 migrants that have reached Malta they
are now on another ship in Carentan I
think it's appropriate to put our newly
arrivals in currenty but of course we
also need more of solidarity between
member states and this is what I'm
working on for the new proposal that I'm
gonna present yeah but the Commission's
been calling for more solidarity on this
for five years and just a month ago the
EU stopped court ruled that Poland
Hungary and the Czech Republic had
broken the law by refusing to host
refugees to help East the ease the burn
from Greece and Italy so you go on
crying in the wind and shouting that
there needs to be more solidarity
they've no
intention of coming into line with your
requests to share the burden of the
migrants Poland Hungary no intention
whatsoever this is not true we can see
right now are they were so showing
solidarity practice when we are
relocating unaccompanied minors from
Greece right now in the pandemic crisis
they are being relocated to other member
states we started with eight member
states ready to do the relocation and
now we are have I think it's 11 1 now
they are ready to do it some more are
joining in I have been traveling a lot
before they're traveling restrictions to
man I met with all the Member States to
have dialogues in closed rooms on the
new pact on migration and asylum and of
course I know from the beginning it's
gonna be difficult there are different
views on different ambitions from
different member states but I must say
that after these consultation with
member states are more optimistic of the
possibility to find a common solution
than I was before I started this
dialogue so of course a lot of things
being a commission are being working
together a lot of things are of course
difficult but that's why we need also
what we need is cooperation and what we
need politicians with our ambitions to
deal with this problems and I do think
it's possible to reach an agreement also
on migration and assignment well I don't
know what you learned though of course
it's difficult I don't know what your
optimism is based on when you have 19
thousand migrants crammed into a camp on
the Greek island of Lesbos that was
built for 3,000 or a dirty deal with
Libya that has seen thousands
incarcerated in appalling conditions
abused and even sold as slaves in
programs as a result of programs that
the EU is funding to this day I'm not
sure what your optimism is based on I
just told you my optimist is based on
the dialogue I have with all the member
states with a
political parties pull your families in
Parliament and that we could see now
even though we have a lot of problems of
course caused by the pandemic and a lot
of problems in each member states caused
by the crisis we are relocating
unaccompanied minors from these
overcrowded camps on the Greek islands
relocating P but there's gonna be 1600
and a procedure have been quicker than
anybody have foreseen even though we
have these problems so there is there
are a lot of signs also that is
optimistic but I will not say that we do
not have problems and challenges but the
fact that people are coming irregular as
migrants and refugees total to the
European Union is not a failure for
European Union this is a challenge that
we have to deal with and I'm convinced
that we can do it together
it is a failure when 19,000 are locked
up in a camp that is only designed for
3,000 and your programs funding the
among other things the Libyan Coast
Guard result in hundreds and thousands
of people being incarcerated against
their will raped beaten and sold sold as
slaves aren't you ashamed of the
programs that you that you fund in this
direction no shame no shame no shame at
all you're happy about the situation in
Libya situation in Libya but I may I
just answer your question I'm not
ashamed what we are doing from the
European Union I do not see how that
very very dangerous and a bad situation
in Libya would be better if the European
Union was not there helping refugees to
be relocated out of these camps in Libya
helping people for voluntary returns out
of Libya to their home countries if we
were not there if we were not there to
helping out trying to teach on the
Libyan coast guard on humanitarian
rights what would be better if
European Union was not there I can't see
it alright Commissioner Hoover Johansson
it's been a great pleasure having you on
conflict zone thank you very much indeed
for your time thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]